so what I'm saying to you if you look at
the only religion that is standing and
guests this Antichrist movement is Islam
you know this all this Liberal Liberal
and all liberalism lgbtq how has been
forced upon people how the only illusion
that standing firm I guess is not
backing down it's Islam Christian the
reason that they see the usual Angus
Islam because for example the only
religion that stands are up that no
alcohol Society against alcohol we can
guess sexualizing women we understand we
are gambling we are guests we and guess
what they call it usually because that
destroys societies even some people can
benefit from it but overall people been
destroyed so they look as Islam would
you like my opinion
Services
as a threat for them and what is Islam
is what Islam is not just for you to be
you know it's not the most Islam is for
the people and for the Elites for the
government to understand so as for
Christianity is dying in the western
world
Africa and Caribbean are the Europeans
the same people that Force Christianity
upon our forefathers and our ancestors
have left it completely in the stand the
only religion they see is Islam but what
is very sad when we see Christians who
believe in God unite and with the
atheists with others groups and guess
Islam
the points are only points were
absolutely spot on offering Islam right
they like um
Christianity should be more zealous on
its fight we are but there's not many
rules proper Christians who profess to
be Christian right so Islam are zealous
against um ex anti-lgbtq love that loved
it they're against
um abortion like all Christians all
Christians should be yeah everything
what you're saying every Christian
should be every Christian should be
against what you're talking about every
Christian and you know that yeah I'm a
totally 100 against all what you just
said there and most of every Christian
that I know should be
this side
oh the winning team it's not going to be
a winner
no yeah yeah
no problem why do you catch your name
sorry
so the point where I'm getting that is
this there's gonna come a time yeah
there's going to come a time you can't
say it will remember my words every
single one here there's gonna come a
time
when the West Rises up against Islam
yeah because Islam if you you look on
the hole everyone's going to come inside
the audience has been raised them what
are you talking about we went for the
worst man
well assistant the Iraq was destroyed
because of fake lies Afghanistan and you
think about the Western bro yeah
the Russia now become problems Russia
stay this way you know for us to be safe
no problems no why Christianity not
speaking out do you know what
Christianity for example to make it
clear to you to understand where I'm
coming from you have your Christian
preachers here day in out every Sunday
yeah who data attack in Islam but to be
honest
paper boy
no that's what I'm saying that's what
I'm saying
in the park they don't talk yeah what is
bringing down Christianity while of
Christians have led Christianity
some of it because of this wave life in
the western world that affect them no no
no not all of it some of it will agree
but some of it is disgusting against it
yeah no doubt about that the point here
is that what you have to understand the
Christians attacking the Muslim when the
reality maturity of Christians will have
Christianity because of liberalism not
because of Islam you understand but
those guys who left Christianity either
they end up atheist or they become what
Muslims because they say Islam is a
practical religion Christianity is Not
Practical religion believe it is that
for a seasoning Edition well I know that
Jesus is God you don't have to get on
but Jesus Is God absolutely but listen
listen to what I'm saying listen to One
chamber listen to what I'm saying now we
believe a real Christian believes yeah
when you're talking about Antichrist
that the far right of antichrist the
liberal this liberal gay transgender
whatever Madness
disgusting yeah Abomination yeah right
that is Antichrist yeah so we believe
that the far right Antichrist we believe
that's antiques what we also believe
that Islam is Antichrist I don't listen
to what I'm saying this is what I'm
trying to say it is antiquized no no
Christ is not Christ I don't know who he
is yeah our class makes more sense than
you guys
your Christ is a good become a baby
someone says nothing listening
now you're missing the point the reason
that Western World of Christianity
because you believe doesn't make any
sense
the Muslim world have no less Islam
now when you come to children in our
time or young people you said you know
God the almighty the greatest the most
powerful become a baby someone should
not be this doesn't make any sense man
understand you know it doesn't make any
sense so the crucial they look at Islam
you know what there's only one God who
is a perfect God he's not in need of his
creation self-sufficient it makes sense
the problem is it like a manifestation
he said you know what I'm saying
so the enemy will send these people in
and then you know
you have to know why Christians are
leaving Christianity why not because
it's liberalism to be honest even if
there's not a Buddhism Christians if
there's not thinking deeply not just
deeply in a normal way of thinking
doesn't make any sense god with Almighty
the greatest all-powerful become a baby
someone should not be
I'm breastfeed him and got beat up do
you believe do you believe there was a
devil yes I do do you believe the devil
is corrupt in this whole world yes
they're Democrat and yeah he's corrupted
in this whole world yeah right so he's
coming out he's poisoning the minds of
the media points in the minds of
churches yeah so when you've got some
churches that will marry men for
instance yeah they're going completely
against the Bible
that's right all right so the end so the
enemy is poisoning poisoning corrupting
the minds of the unbelievers that's what
the Bible says about the devil corrupted
the most corruption is you believe in
God become baby well listen so the Bible
says the God of this world yeah meaning
the devil has blinded the minds of the
unbelievers yeah so that they cannot see
the illumination of the glory of Jesus
Christ who is the image of God yeah
that's what he said so you have been
blinded Islam has been blinded and I
told you for why I'm literally for what
I personally this is my opinion
all right one sec this is my my opinion
yeah that when Muhammad was getting
Revelations right you can say what you
want to say and I'll say well you're not
dealing with my points no listen you got
off topic
you're dive into it let me speak okay I
believe for that 23 years of Revelations
that he was getting from the angel that
the angel was a fallen demonic Angel
okay and he's come up with your Devil's
Doctrine that's what I believe analyze
that as a man of thinking should we
analyze that yes
Analyze That does the devil Teach You To
Worship a perfect God who does not
become weak and get bitter by people
moment that's go teach does the devil
teach you you should believe in God who
is perfect no one can overpower him
that's good that will teach you that
I step by step to understand we are
after night that's God teach you to
worship God who is perfect no no no wait
wait step by step step by step
no no utilize our intellect that God
gave us
now if someone comes to me and he said
to me worship God who is perfect there's
nothing like unto him the greatest he's
not in need of no one everyone's in need
of him he's one God I said you know what
that's the code I want to rely on
another person come worship God become a
baby someone should not be someone beat
him up I said bro I'm more about
powerful than you God if someone beat
him up I can pick up that guy baby which
one is the satanic one the Goda is
perfect he has not begin to end he
overpowered everything all the time oh
God become baby someone beat him up
[Music]
people will know
you see listen
listeners
ask them a question I have respect ask
them a question if someone comes to you
he said to you Donny worship God who is
perfect he has no big begin to end he
Powers he overpower everything all the
times remember oh God become a baby
someone beat him up which one Jesus has
got no beginning I'm not asking about
Jesus I'm asking himself
Jesus Christ
you cannot answer questions
let's go
[Applause]
anyway don't they answer my question
before you leave
let us repeat it last repeat last sent
me the question
[Music]
my brothers